[Music]
don't forget that Harry and William are
playing stormtroopers in Star Wars the
last Jedi which just opened today and so
many fans were camping out at the famous
Chinese Theater that the LAPD added
officers to keep everybody safe the
movie is expected to make as much as
four hundred and twenty nine million
dollars this weekend alone Carly stills
with the cast including Daisy Ridley so
they got right to the big rumor is Daisy
really hanging up for lightsaber you
almost broke the internet when you said
you're going to be stepping away from
Rey at the end okay let's clear it out
what is well know firstly that was at
the end of a very long day that ends a
very long shoot but no we were talking
about where the the trilogy's going
whatever it is all I said was as far as
I was concerned when I signed on I was
signing on two seven eight nine I don't
know about any plans feeling that that's
for Disney that's for anyone else in
charge she was not into it
I'm well in my mind that is where the
story ends a trilogy represent a
beginning a middle and an end
but I don't know beyond that raised
confrontation with Luke is one of the
most anticipated moments to watch John
boyega tells us to expect a fast start
the last Jedi hits the ground running
either end of the last movie obviously
got into that crazy fight with kylo Ren
in defense of Rey I ended up getting
he's back slashed so now he's in
recovery but wakes up with array on his
mind because he still feels he's in that
moment so it's up to Poe to bring him
right up to speed in terms of spin
another thing to watch carrie fisher's
final Star Wars appearance look for a
farewell to the princess was your
favorite memory of Carrie we had such a
passionate relationship because we were
mad for each other and then we were mad
at each other and not speaking we
reached a point in our lives were there
there was a real comfort zone she could
relax around me because she knew I was
she knew that I hadn't changed in all
those years I wasn't trying to angling
to get something
Oliver well mark also told us that he
can make Kerry laughs and Kerry love
that good and look at this because just
hours before the movie open at the
Chinese Theatre Kerry's brother Todd
paid tribute to her with a plaque that
reads we'd allow these here and we do
too for sure
[Music]
you